I've got a $20 bill here I can buy stuff
but wait this is just a piece of paper
who says anyone will trust that this is
worth 20 bucks money is only useful if
at least two people agree that it can be
trusted a new documentary asks what
makes money trustworthy it has to be
reliable like a clock says Steve Forbes
so it has to be fixed in value
60 minutes an hour 60 seconds in a
minute imagine if that floated each day
that would make life chaotic so
throughout history people needed a way
to assign a fixed value to money well
the best mechanism for this would be
some kind of commodity that's permanent
easily transported easily understood by
everyone and that medium was of course
gold not of course people have pegged
money to agricultural crops or salt
that's where we got the word salary but
gold was more reliable and once it was
accepted as currency money begins to
create a kind of mobility in people's
lives that they never had before but
gold heavy it's hard to carry around
that limited trade so people invented
banks the Knights Templar developed a
system where he said well you can just
dispose in your money here with us and
then when you need some even withdraw
from your account this enabled the
peasants to travel Europe about being a
danger of being robbed that enabled much
more trade you could sell a bond in
London and build a railroad in India and
as a result the seemingly resource-poor
speck of Europe became the financial
center of the world then in the u.s.
Alexander Hamilton fixed the dollar to
gold dollar became to be seen as a
rock-solid currency where he could go
anywhere in the world and they would
accept that dollar and the world boot
wages soared it was an incredible period
of wealth creation don't get me wrong
four examples of terrible deprivation
and hunger but it was a time of great
material progress and the monetary
foundation of that progress lay in full
standard but as usual rulers would
debase the currency the Emperor Nero
they would call in all the coin melt
them down reissue them of course with
his picture on them but with less gold
Rome's decline was very closely
associated with the decline of its money
when you change the value of money
you're stealing property that happened
in Germany after World War 1 to print
money to pay for the conflict Europe and
the u.s. went off goal and after losing
the war Germany suffered the infamous
vimar hyperinflation we said to Germany
you have to pay back the world the
nation's government certainly couldn't
pay that much money so Germany began to
print and print it too much you go to a
restaurant and you find that your needle
is going to cost a thousand marks a and
you order it you eat it and by the time
the bill comes is that a thousand marks
becomes sixteen thousand bucks in the
United States around that time
politicians created our own crisis
President Herbert Hoover signed into law
the smoot-hawley Tariff it's sweeping
taxes on thousands of foreign products
triggered a global trade war this set in
motion events leading to the Great
Depression with millions unemployed
government searched for solutions they
tighten the money and the country
literally ran out of money so in some
towns there was no money left
clothes I am going to establish a
government market for gold Franklin
Roosevelt in an attempt to revive a
struggling US economy confiscated
private holdings of gold and devalued
the dollar so all kinds of
constitutional freedoms and this moral
commitment to maintain the value of the
money were swept out Roosevelt really
didn't know what to do so he kind of
tried every Theory the way people will
do like a cook in a kitchen trying
different spices near the end of World
War two Western governments met to try
to stabilize currencies the world
returned to gold based money and it was
enormously successful those two decades
from 1950 1960 where are the most
successful economically of any time but
then again a president abandoned the
gold standard i have directed secretary
connolly to suspend temporarily the
convertibility of the dollar the value
of the dollar plunged since then the
dollar has lost more than 80% of its
value that's one reason that today some
believe the future lies in crypto
currencies like Bitcoin bitcoin is both
the currency and a payment system so
it's like PayPal and US dollars combined
into one but so far
crypto currencies price changes make
them hard to use as currency could we
transact with Bitcoin today oh I'll pay
you 20 Bitcoin if you come to work for
me
that will be your annual salary was that
the Bitcoin it was worth 980 at the
beginning of 2017 or the Bitcoin that
was worth 20 2001 2018 began so what
does the future hold here's the
documentaries concluding argue the only
way to restore trust is for the United
States to return to the system that
worked for most of its history Gold has
proven to be the preferred monetary
standard these days most economists
suppose a gold standard Milton Friedman
opposed it but this documentary will
give you background to help you decide
what you think after all we do need
sound money with a stable value all this
is the
struggle for trust and money ultimately
does depend on trust you can see the
full documentary on some PBS stations or
stream it at in money we trust org